this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's going to be reacting to
the game we receive the most requests
for
seriously a lot of you asked for this
it's hunt showdown this version
with the funky chain belt feed is i
think
based on this
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down do let us know in
the comments below make sure to
subscribe for more videos exactly like
this
and if you want to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
what was that so i'm getting the sense
that this is not a
realistic take on the western genre it's
not a game that i
had even seen prior to being asked about
it for this so this is pretty much new
to me but
where i am familiar and comfortable is
with the single action army
cult revolver guessing from the state of
the thing and the lack of grips that
there is a
deterioration repair maintenance
mechanic going on
more importantly apart from your 45 colt
rounds which would be quite handy this
thing's got this
what what at first i thought was like a
skull smasher as i sometimes called
pommel on the bottom of the grip which
is not something that the cult came with
but it's something that you could fit
weld on there or something if you wish
what this appears to be is actually a
very short
knife and we're getting some um walking
dead style
head kills using this incredibly
short uh obtusely angled blade
[Applause]
i'm picking up the customization options
here because i know the
colt 1872 revolver is in the game this
is a reproduction
we don't have one in the collection in
the royal armouries sadly this version
with the weird funky chain belt
feed is i think based on this
this is the treebee chain
gun it works much like
a single action revolver
it revolves not a cylinder but a chain
of
uh chambers to the next position
pulling the trigger i will ease it down
fires off
that chamber lock it again to revolve to
the next one so
pretty much like the game this is a
percussion though so you'd have to
muzzle load each of these chambers
um whereas what we see there is slightly
fudged reload animation where the empty
case is somehow pulled out
without using the ejector so they're
just doing it manually
and they're just kind of glossing over
how that happens which is fair enough
the 18 to 22 cult would be interesting
enough
because they're they rarely show up in
western fiction but to sort of combine
it with the tree b
or hey maybe they've come up with that
idea on their own i don't know
but um we certainly have a victorian
equivalent of that in the collection
which is good
i like that if it wasn't for the fact
you only get one shot that's
almost like an ideal zombie weapon
that's a 12 gauge
single barrel break open shotgun they
were very common in the old west
that looked like it might be in either
johnson or
stevens or something and it's obviously
been modified with a
quite a cool hatchet attachment and is
is drastically
cut down if this is like 1880s and the
cartridges are black powder
you would want a uh smokeless powder
loaded cartridge
basically because if you're firing black
powder out of that shorter barrel
it's going to be pretty weak the burnt
rate of black powder is
is different and wouldn't be hugely
effective so we'll have to assume that
those are nitro
cartridges um incidentally the
cartridges looks
quite authentic there's a tendency in
games to just stick modern looking
cartridges
which don't look totally out of place
but those with a different color and the
detail of the head stamp that actually
looked like
some they dug out some late 19th century
early 20th century maybe
cartridges to model there
that's a bit of a wacky choice there for
old west america
i'm not quite sure it's probably some
law
or story reason why there's a russian
service revolver from the
end of the 19th century 1895 model the
gantt revolver
as to why that's in the game interesting
because it's got the
um granite device or a version
of it it's actually not just a
suppressor it's got a
sort of sabo in in a modified form of
the cartridge
that stops all the gas from escaping
that's why it's not huge and sticking
off the end of the gun was because it's
it traps the gas as the bullet leaves
the barrel
and then as you revolve to the next
chamber
releases that trapped wind as it were
so not actually a conventional silencer
as to whether it be quite as quiet as
that i don't think anybody knows
for sure because i've not seen that
version of the device
ever and i've not seen it since i've
heard of it being tested there's no
reason to think it wouldn't be very
quiet based on how it works but whether
it would be quite as quiet as that
can't say
[Music]
um this this has confused me greatly
this
bizarre contraption because it it is
very familiar it looks like uh joseph
huwatt's
conversion of the ross rival it's got
all the features of that
conversion but it is also definitely
based on a
mosin a russian mosin rifle which
doesn't make any sense
because the huat because it's a
conversion of the ross the ross
is a straightforward design so you just
have to make the bolt get pulled to the
rear
and then push forward again to chamber
around can't just do that to a
to a motion which is a turn bolt you
have to lift up the bolt
quite drastically and then push it or
pull it to the rear
you could probably do it but it would
need a huge
machined cam plate like some of the
enfield conversions
that turn rearward movement of the
piston into upward and rearward movement
of a term
bolt i know i'm over analyzing this but
that's kind of my job
an iconic but not super common
western pistol is the le mans
very interesting because of well not
only nine shots in the cylinder
which is uncommon for a revolver but
also
a 20 gauge shotgun second barrel
the video game version in this case is
quite different they've based it on
a real version which is as far as i know
it was built
for the tv so if you've seen the
westworld tv show you've seen
this version of the gun this is a
percussion muzzle loader so you'd have
to stoke up
nine chambers and the shotgun barrel
with it with a wad and some shot
ahead of time and then in a realistic
fighting situation that's your 10 shots
you don't get to reload it
in the 1870s we see older designs like
this
cartridge converted that didn't happen
with the lamat as far as i know
but there is this movie magic version
that's in westworld
where you have to take the gun apart it
increases loading speed a bit
but it doesn't allow you to reload it
like we see in the game
what they've done is take it another
step for further and completely redesign
the gun
so that instead of the front barrel
assembly coming off
it pivots downwards that would not work
because there is no way to latch this
cylinder shut which is critical if you
don't have a top strap
you need some way of latching the
cylinder shut that is super strong
so they fudged it which is fine i don't
you can't put
a percussion firearm in a game like this
without making it uber powerful to
compensate
so they haven't that's fair enough
was a bit of a curious fighting pistol
for any situation actually but um what
we've just seen
is a version of the c sharps
patent der engine it does work pretty
much as seen so you
put it on half [ __ ] press a catch under
the barrel which
you don't see really in the game slide
the barrel unit forwards
and then you you put your little
cartridges in there
you're not going to get much powder in
that case so the power is going to be
quite
low so you're relying purely on the
bullet diameter to do the damage
and from what i saw in the clip there
this thing seems to be a bit of a beast
so i'd say it's probably too powerful
for what it is hey maybe it's charmed or
something i don't know
it's a nice bit of variety and these are
quite nice
antiques
the old reliable sharks rifle very
common
in the west for things like buffalo
hunting and we do
see scoped versions like that you
definitely wouldn't want to be
clobbering
anything with any scope rifle to be fair
but especially not a
something of that vintage um the
slightest knock could easily put that
out of zero
and suddenly you're missing your single
shot you've only got one
shot for this design of course the other
thing i noticed about it
is the hammer something very strange
going on with the hammer
with the sharps the percussion sharks
you had to
half [ __ ] before you open the lever and
do your thing
because you needed to be able to cap the
nipple
the metallic cartridge version which is
what we see here
there's no need to be fiddling with the
hammer at all so
whereas the the reload animation has has
the character sort of
semi-cock it open the lever put the
cartridge in and then sort of
just sort of gets decocked at one point
and then cocked again before firing you
don't need to do any of that you just
drop the lever cartridge in lever up
[ __ ] it fire it
pausing variety of shotguns is good
we've also got the
spencer 1882 which is a relatively early
in fact
importantly early pump action slide
action shotgun
it's got an unusual action by modern
standards that
flips up out of the top of the gun as
you see there the incidentally
people are wondering the what looks like
a second trigger in the trigger
guard is is the action bar lock which is
something that's on modern pump action
guns as well although you're not aware
of it
in fiction because the gun is never
empty so
but that's what that's what locks the
gun shut i suppose a
a word on the fictional names of all the
guns in the game
because that one's visible on the top of
the the receiver
having having looked it up i've i
realized that all the names
are what i would normally call legally
different but in most cases
there's no one around that would sue you
for calling this to spencer
i don't think i'm not gonna get into the
legal side of it i'm not a lawyer
there's definitely
a stylistic choice to fictionalize the
companies in the game
and i don't know why that's the case
necessarily
[Applause]
this is actually a really good addition
to a game like this if you if you were
having to hunt
supernatural creatures in a late 19th
century time period
you would want something like a big game
rifle and that's what that's what this
is
and to get through a thick skull like
that you need some serious power so this
is um
apparently a 600 nitro which which is
600
nitro express which is one of the
cartridges developed by
the company uh jeffries in the late 19th
century
the word nitro refers to nitro powders
or smokeless propellants
which are obviously more effective more
efficient cleaner burning
woods it was almost like a hybrid so a
giant bottle
bottle shaped and sized cartridge with a
round nose bullet
using nitro powder to propel it to
decent velocities high velocities
so would work nicely on these creatures
if you'd like to donate to the royal
armories museum we have links in the
description i also have a book coming
out
fairly shortly on the british bullpup
firearms so
head over to the headstamp publishing
website if you'd like to
pick up a copy of that thanks guys
[Music]
you